well to discuss the latest twists and
turns in the race for number 10 I'm
joined from Westminster by Katherine
Foster she's a journalist at the Sunday
Times and The Guardian column columnist
and author Owen Jones good afternoon to
you both thanks a lot for coming in
Michael Gove probably wanted us to be
talking more about v80 then committing
crimes snorting cocaine
he says he's fortunate enough not to
have gone to prison but how damaging do
you think this is for his campaign Owen
well it's what should be damaging about
it isn't the fact that he's admitted to
doing something which if as a country
will be honest millions of people have
done millions of people have taken
illegal drugs at some point in their
lives but the hypocrisy of people like
Michael Gove who not only support
policies which destroy the lives of
other people for doing the exact same
thing but actually imposed them Michael
Gove himself imposed a lifetime ban on
teachers who talked cocaine and he's
also a man of course who wrote articles
when he was a journalist condemning the
use of drugs and supporting the
disastrous failure of the war on drugs
we we have a situation where if you are
a privileged white politician in power
and with influence then you can dismiss
taking drugs as long as high jinks as a
youthful indiscretion there wasn't that
young at the time as just a bit of a
joke or one of those things he's allowed
a life before politics all that kind of
stuff well as the young black people in
Hackney can be stopped and searched
found with drugs and then have
life-changing consequences criminalized
struggling to find work and indeed for
example someone aspired to be a teacher
could have their career destroyed
because of Michael Goes policy so I
think if we're gonna have a rational
response to this we should condemn the
fact that if you are at the top of
society and with power you can take
drugs and get away with it but but but
for so many other people particularly
disproportionately poorer and black
people then they are likely to have
often their lives destroyed as a
consequence so if they want to stop
being hypocrites then let's have a
national debate and conversation about
ending the failed so
world war on drugs because this wanton
hypocrisy with a parade of conservative
politicians now coming out talking about
the drug taking that they've they that
they've had in their youth whilst
criminalizing so many of the people for
doing the same thing it's an absurdity
okay Katherine what do you think do you
think this is about crime or is it now
hypocrisy well I think it's about both I
mean Michael Gove is very apologetic and
deeply regrets it but the bottom line is
although many people take drugs there is
a link between as such a Javid was was
on Sophie rich this morning saying
people middle class people taking drugs
at parties that get away with it there
is a link I mean cressida dick once said
and people that take drugs have blood on
their hands which is obviously very
strong but you know there is truth in
that there is a link between taking
drugs that are poverty and you know the
drugs trade people being thrown in jail
people losing their lives and so I think
it is very damaging he was of course
Justice Secretary and so you know deeply
involved in people being put in prison
often as a result of the drug trade okay
so oh and where do we go from here do
you think this should disqualify him
possibly from the leadership campaign
well in a just world what should
disqualify a politician from a position
of power is to take drugs and then
support criminalizing and destroying the
lives of others for doing the same thing
in a job we don't live in that just
society I'm afraid but what if we were
gonna have a mature and rational
conversation we should talk about how
the so-called war on drugs ever since it
started many decades ago drug use has
only exploded since that is fueled
massive criminal and criminality just as
prohibition did in the United States
yeah we should be talking about the
thousands of people who've died because
of the so-called war on drugs in the
same way that so many people died
because of prohibition in America that
instead we could talk about regulating
drugs and taking it out of the hands of
criminals but instead we end up with a
situation where if it is one rule for
those at the top and it's one rule for
everybody else if you take drugs you
know and one commentator put together
very eloquently I thought
you know if you did stop and search and
applied it to conservative politicians
you'd actually have a very decent rate
of success compared to for example all
those young black people on the streets
of Hackney or Moss ID who have often
very aggressive stop and search with
nothing on them because for a start the
government's own data shows that black
people take drugs at a lower rate than
white people that are far more likely to
be stopped and searched on suspicion of
having drugs and if they're found with
possession of either cannabis or cocaine
they are far more likely to be charged
in a white person in the same situation
so that should be the debate yes I think
you should be disqualified but I think
they should all be disqualified for the
same thing but unfortunately you know
they will get away with this hypocrisy
whilst every single year thousands of
lives will be destroyed because of
policies they support because of
behavior that they themselves do but it
you can get away with it if you're a
posh white Tory but you can't if you're
a young black man in my side or Hackney
do a grey Kathryn well I don't think
anybody is going to be disqualified for
this I mean we now have a situation I
think six of the current eleven
leadership candidates have admitted to
taking drugs in some form or whether
it's been cannabis or cannabis lar see
or whatever so I don't think that's
going to happen at all but I do think
it's damaging for Michael Gove and
especially you know should he make the
final two candidates were 160,000
members of the Conservative Party get to
vote I mean lots of metropolitan people
may not think this is a big deal but the
membership is really quite conservative
and the average age is also very high so
I think this is damaging for him
definitely
Owen do you think if it does get down to
go V Johnson and Johnson will win I
think he's got every chance of winning
and I have to say you know one of the
I'm afraid big faults at the moment in
this whole debate is the lack of
scrutiny of Boris Johnson who is very
likely to become the prime minister of
this country in a matter of weeks why
why aren't we asking does he still think
that gay people should be called bum
boys does he still think that equal
marriage should be compared to Timur
marrying a dog does he still believe
that black people should be called
pickaninnies with watermelon smiles does
he still think that it's acceptable to
compare Muslim women to bank robbers and
to letterboxes why should we trust
somebody he was sacked twice for
dishonesty one spies newspaper and once
by a conservative leader is somebody who
once conspired with a criminal friend to
beat up a journalist fit for high office
is somebody who wrote one column
supporting romaine and another column
supporting leave is that somebody who's
driven by anything else other than his
own career we're not talking about these
discussions and I could go on by the way
the fact that senior conservative aides
say that when they he was in meetings he
couldn't concentrate he wasn't briefed
he was he was an embarrassment one of
them said one career diplomat described
serving under him as foreign secretaries
the only time he was embarrassed to
represent his own country but we're not
having this discussion because all too
often I'm afraid to say and I speak as
somebody who has worked in the British
media now for the best part of a decade
Boris Johnson is treated as a bit of a
circus a bit of a joke a bit of a laugh
but he is somebody who was peddled
racism
he's serially dishonest he's a charlatan
but we're not having that conversation
because again and it's worth emphasizing
this if you are from a posh background
you can more or less get away with
anything in this country as a reward you
think he has been apart from this
interview he's done this morning he has
been notably absent from this campaign
hasn't he he has and I think that's
deliberate policy because the biggest
obstacle to Boris becoming Prime
Minister is Boris himself Boris says
things that perhaps he shouldn't say
sets the cat amongst the pigeons so I
think there's been a deliberate strategy
of let's keep Boris out of the news he's
lost lots of weight he's got a haircut
he's looking more serious he's given
this interview to my paper my colleague
Tim Shipman in the Sunday Times today
which in which we've learned he says I'm
going to go I'm not going to give the
thirty nine billion and let me get a
deal I'm prepared to walk away etc etc
but I do think going forward and if we
get you know the television debates
we've learnt what happened
time when the conservative leadership
you know the process was curtailed when
Andrea led some dropped out and we had
Theresa May appointed by default so to
speak and that didn't work out very well
I mean she wasn't tested she was a
terrible campaign and look where that
has got the Conservative Party so I
think it is really important that Boris
should participate in the TV debates and
when they happen I don't think he'll be
that keen but I think we need to see him
if he might well be prime minister of
this country yeah I mean with all due
respect I think that contribution itself
reveals part of the problem we're more
likely in the British media to hear
people discussing him losing weight and
getting a haircut than the fact that he
once conspired with a criminal on the
phone to talk about beating up a
journalist all for example being sacked
for dishonesty including by The Times
newspaper you'll see your sister paper
for dishonesty the fact that he's
somebody he was peddled bigotry and
racism once spoke of course not that
long ago about jokes about clearing the
bodies from Libya to turn it into a
tourist resort this is somebody he was
regarded as an embarrassment across
Europe he reduced this country to the I
mean the many things you can say about
Teresa may and I have said them but one
of the one of the many abject things she
did is appoint this clown and a
dangerous clown as foreign secretary and
I just think all too often the
superficial coverage you can if you you
know a guy he's posh and and and speaks
a bit a Latin and is swallowed a
thesaurus and ruffles your hair
occasionally like this you can more or
less get away with anything and then
half the political lobby go get the
knees it's absurd
oh and Catherine I'm afraid we're gonna
have to leave it there but thank you
both for coming on this afternoon thank
you